if you're just joining us rudy giuliani
is sweating his face off explaining to
us why trump really won the election
again inspectors
every state
almost every approved this
was thrown away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to have been a dead
person
that could have been not filled out wait
he's saying there was a dead person in
the
envelope rudy's about to have actual
drops of sweat coming off of his brow i
mean is this a normal amount i don't
know how hot it is in the room but this
something seems very wrong here all
being the lawsuit that comes out duty's
melting arizona is is a state that we're
looking at very very carefully strongly
looking at it i would say we're probably
i assume
she's working if she's working
i'd like to read them all to you but i
don't have the time
you should have had the time and energy
to go look for them
that's your job
like it's my job to defend the president
it's lane
michigan wisconsin
is he bleeding did you see is he
bleeding from his ear
what on
and we're getting he's gotta get off the
stage and there are other aspects of
this fraud on the morning of them
someone's gotta get him a napkin they
were gonna count the these this new kind
of battle
i've never seen anything like this
thing what on earth it's getting onto
his shirt now chicken and it was conch
any jury would accept because they heard
this evidence
that somebody had this plan this is
insane maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sap from an oak tree or a
maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup should the city describe
that to you oh my god it's all over his
face
he's gonna need a towel dealing with
evidence i don't know guys it's sounding
like trump won isn't it based on this
and i was called by the biggest dumps
they call them dumps big massive dumps
big massive dumpster
big massive dump
sure sure
big massive dumpster
massive dumps
huge dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania huge dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania huge dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania huge dumps
big massive dumps
huge dumps were happening all over the
country
what is going on here big massive dump
huge dumps were happening all over the
country
what is going on here big massive dumps
the fbi and department of justice i
don't know maybe they're involved and
i'm sure you felt that way that i'm sure
you felt that way
the fbi and department of justice i
don't know maybe they're involved they
call them dumb
big massive dumps
you're a laughingstock
all right wow let's get away from that
because it we can't it's just going on
for too too long
too
long i think we might be able to say we
have two events tonight
and we are
on the precipice of the california
gubernatorial recall it's such a special
day that i'm wearing my orange shirt
because i want to know the oranges of
everything we're going to be seeing over
the next couple of days
in the next few minutes we're going to
be hearing from president joe biden
and he is in california
he is going to be talking about this new
3.5 trillion dollar proposal he's going
to be talking about the wildfires it's
unclear if he will give advice about
raking the forest floors we know trump
was really big on not only sinks and
showers and elements of bathrooms but
also on raking
uh the forest floors so we will see if
um
biden may even demo raking the ground
for us we will see
then joe biden is going to be at a rally
for gavin newsom now that's hours from
now
my hope is to be long asleep by the time
that happens but after joe biden
larry elder is going to be having a
rally larry elder is i mean listen where
we are with the california recall if
gavin newsom gets recalled
le this man here will almost certainly
become the governor of california and
that is really really scary and in a
moment we're going to be looking at some
larry elder clips
we're going to be looking at polling
we're going to be looking at rose
mcgowan
who now i guess is supporting larry
elder she actually seems to have had a
psychotic break complete mental health
crisis i don't know diagnosed
undiagnosed unclear
but um it's all pretty weaponized i
think is the way that i would put it i
have an unban request for you guys
finally we do have one i have voicemails
i have thank yous i have um what else do
i have oh because we are today and
tomorrow we are fighting against this
recall in california we have a new
coupon code the code is no recall no
it's so you've got total recall
no recall is the opposite of that and
that's where we are no recall no recall
and that'll save you save you so much
money off of a membership it makes me
blush
and so i'm not going to tell you but i
will thank everybody who grabs one of
those memberships let's get right into
it because i have so much material i do
want to quickly thank fastn triple six
life is good
grim reaper ryan83
and master
all of whom have signed up via twitch
and twitch prime and other twitch
elements
um
i think that's about all i have to say
about it we will open phone lines
discord lines if we get to 100 and i
think it would be really a beautiful day
now in terms of streams for the next for
the rest of the week
i am open to streaming california
results tomorrow night
my only concern
someone one person told me
we won't know anything until 11 15 p.m
eastern time meaning 8 15 on the west
coast
that just seems pointlessly late i mean
it's just like what are we doing you
know people my bedtime is before that
i'll stay up a little late but you know
what what are we doing
um other people said we won't even
really know the results so just stream
anytime we'll stream what's been
happening in california there will
certainly be allegations of fraud and
fraud we'll we can stream that and
either way we're not going to know the
results and then that'll be it
and then other people just don't even
know who i am and have no idea what i'm
talking about when i say maybe i'll
stream tomorrow
and i guess i'll just their their
opinion is sort of irrelevant one way or
the other i don't know i'm just not
really sure so that's tomorrow
and then i'm still trying to figure out
what time is the september 18th trump
riot
it's weird to be like there's a trump
riot scheduled they say it's going to be
peaceful
but i've got a wedding to go to in the
evening on saturday
if the riot is scheduled for like noon i
would absolutely stream even 2 3 p.m
eastern time i can probably stream until
about
let me think when do i need to get in
the shower
probably until 4 30 or something like
that
so if at any point anybody gets some
information about what time the rally is
scheduled for on saturday which may or
may not turn into a a riot um let me
know
and then we'll look very strongly at
schedule now also if you know what time
the rally starts but you also know what
time they'll start rioting that would be
useful to know as well that's a good
point for sure and in fact if they could
move the riot to sunday i would prefer
it because then we could do a much
longer and wider stream yeah i mean it's
kind of
or maybe i could get the wedding moved
either way no the wedding must stay
uh all right i want to say thank you to
james quinn who is the first person in
history to sign up on my website with
the coupon code no recall and his new
member number six today very much
appreciate that james let's make james
proud and let's not leave him alone at
the top of the mountain with the code no
recall
let's keep things going all right a few
super chats michael says david i work
for the new york state government
vaccines are mandated one of my
co-workers is quitting and moving to
texas as a result
all right well
have fun
um
atari says sir people talk about eating
the bugs living in the pods but have you
looked around lately
i don't know that for that reference
big booboo says what are your thoughts
on cristiano returning to manchester i
don't know a thing about it
i follow messi and the argentinian men's
national team and that's basically it
who's cristiano anyway i don't even know
no i'm kidding i know who that is but uh
didn't really like him in mrs doubtfire
so hopefully he's got better better
scripts these days
um okay so let's get into some of these
different things
first and foremost
if we want to just
be empirical
it's looking better and better for gavin
newsom
uh what was at one point basically a
dead heat a month ago
it's now plus 16 plus 15.9 for gavin
newsom keeping gavin newsom so
my hope is let me put it this way
if i were a betting man
even money i'm betting that newsome
stays
okay i'm not really sure by how much
uh everybody must vote
because
we the risk is too big if newsom is
replaced with larry elder
but
but but
what i would love to see
is the recall movement
humiliated
blown out of the water and part of
what's going on is that this is another
one of these pseudo
referenda on trump because larry elder
has been a big pro-trump guy and newsom
has been sort of you know a target of
trump and so there is an element of this
that is kind of like a referendum on
trump as well so we just just need to
absolutely
crush crush crush
speaking of gavin newsom
we're standing by here for joe biden
remember this is just the first of two
events larry elder will be having a big
rally in a little bit unclear if he'll
be joined by rose mcgowan so when joe
biden starts speaking we're going to go
to him actually since it is the eve of
his recall let's listen a little bit to
gavin newsom as well and i know the
president will be speaking a lot about
those opportunities and the next day and
the upcoming weeks as he refers to the
work he's doing to
this historic uh infrastructure package
but i want to just make a point uh mr
president with uh your uh indulgence
that despite the present united states
being here
i would stipulate the most powerful
force on the planet
is is not even the present united states
it's mother nature
she is as others have said
all she is is chemistry biology and
physics she bats last she bats a
thousand
we are dealing with extremes likes of
which we've never dealt with in our
state's history oh yeah one of the
wettest we've ever seen from the
standpoint of water summer we have ever
experienced in california's history
between june and august
a west coast drought that some have
referred to as a mega drought that
arguably began in 2000
the hots are getting a lot hotter the
dries are getting drier and as you saw
on the east coast the united states
where people quite literally were
drowning in their cars the wets are
getting a lot wetter with atmospheric
rivers and the continents
of warming seas and more intense
tropical the sign language uh
interpreter is in sepia tone today by
the challenges and that reality but also
as i noted optimistic uh by not only
california's capacity to work through
situationally and we are the calder fire
that we just visited
uh that took the town of grizzly flats
uh that fire now is 67 percent contained
the dixie fire uh now about three
quarters contained uh situationally
we are battling these wildfires and
making progress but the sustainable
mindset we have is to address these
smash mouth realities and to lead the
conversation a new in this country to
radically change the way we produce and
consume energy
and to continue to lead our
nation-leading efforts as it relates to
low-carbon green growth
california's leadership is demonstrable
california's leadership has been
challenged in the last four years
but those headwinds now are tailwinds
with the biden administration we're not
sparring partners we're working partners
as it relates to issues of climate
change and dealing with didn't this guy
used to date kimberly guilfoyle the
lunatic mania woman that's now dating
don jr the best is yet to come lady am i
misremembering that you took the time to
be here uh but as i began let me end by
saying um
this is not they were married
really issue
we held two summits that's that's weird
governors proactively held with the
president's assistance not only did he
show up to make remarks he stayed until
the end of both conversations i've been
around this business long enough
to note the distinction between people
that are interested in things and people
that are committed
to solving things president united
states commitment is demonstrable now
the third time here physically seeing
the impacts of these wildfires for
himself but his commitments he made in
june
the commitments he made in july
the promises
that he made to follow up he delivered
on
we had specifically four things we
requested of the president united states
all four he delivered on
and so mr president let me also take
this moment not just to thank you for
being here at this critical juncture but
thank you for delivering on your
promises thank you for meeting this
moment head on and thank you for leading
a conversation anew in this country
around resiliency and around painting an
optimistic
picture of the future as we transition
to a low-carbon green growth future and
so with that
let me introduce the president of the
united states joe biden
a lot of buzzwords there dropping them
in
well folks uh
thank you governor for those comments
i say good afternoon and uh
to all
of you here
in this cool hangar
earlier today uh biden's got a long day
ahead of him he's got a rally in like
three hours
in boise idaho
the center located is a locational hub
for our federal firefighting resources
in the region
and we just surveyed some of the damage
of the calder fire here in california
which in less than a month
has wiped out for two hundred thousand
acres
and one thousand structures
homes
precious memories destroyed
air quality to degrade it
local economy stopped in its tracks and
nearly 200 people in the area
forced to live in shelters
everyone in northern california
knows the time of the year
when you can't go outside
when the air will be filled with smoke
and the sky will turn
apocalyptic shade of orange well that's
tough parents worried about keeping
their children
safe in a pandemic
worry about air quality as well
thus far
the nationwide over 44 000 wildfires
have burned
nearly five
million three hundred thousand acres
roughly the size of the state of new
jersey
in california
this year more than 2.2 million acres
have burned
the dixie fire burned nearly 1 million
alone
and we're working closely with governor
newsome to make sure california has
every resource every resource available
to keep families safe
and the governor has led
his state with poise
and strong leadership
he's been an innovator in items of for
long-term solutions
and he and i are both optimistic
these fires are blinking
code red
for our nation
they're gaining frequency and ferocity
and we know what we have to do and it
starts with our firefighters putting
their lives on the line and rugged and
dangerous conditions
i never forget coming out to arizona in
2013
to speak at the memorial of the 19
granite mountain hotshots who gave their
lives
firefighters
are unmatched in their bravery
that's why i took the action i did in
june to ensure that all federal
firefighters earn at least the minimum
wage
and we're working on fundamentally
changing the benefits that are available
to them
fema
has approved 33 fire management
assistance grants to help western states
pay for the cost of fighting these awful
fires
we use the defense production act
to address the shortage in fire hoses
because of the pandemic we found
ourselves in the situation
where there's a backlog
and an awful lot of things
we restarted the idle production line in
oklahoma bringing back to work
and delivering thousands
of new feats of new fire hoses to the
front lines hard to believe
short on fire hoses
in addition
we've tapped dod the department of
defense
for 10 aircraft
20 c-130s a modular airborne
firefighting systems
with those systems
and to help fire suppression
the
rc-26 aircraft to provide critical
imagery from space
they're based in california and they've
now flown over
1 000 missions across the west
250 active duty military troops
on ground uh on the ground at dixie fire
in california working alongside
firefighters
we're sharing satellite imagery to help
detect and monitor fire growth
and the epa is using new technology to
deliver fire smoke and air quality
information directly to people's cell
phones
our friends from canada and australia
are providing help through both
firefighters as well as aircraft
and my buildback better plan
includes billions of dollars for
wildfire preparedness
resilience and response
forest management to restore millions of
acres and to protect homes and public
water sources
this bipartisan bill
includes more than eight billion dollars
of increased resilience
in wildfires
and add uh and to that county and
resolution packages include
the continuing resolution practically 14
billion dollars in disaster needs
including 9 billion for communities hit
by wildfire and drought we're not going
to leave these people in distress
right we know that decades of forest
management decisions
have created hazardous conditions across
the western forest but we can't ignore
the reality
that these wire wildfires are being
supercharged by climate change
it isn't about red or blue states
it's about fires just fires
in the past two weeks i've been to
louisiana
where hurricane ate a hit
and with winds up to 179 miles an hour
gusting
new jersey and new york
walking down the streets main streets
meeting with families and first
responders seeing the destruction of
these disasters caused dreams crushed
lives interrupted
scientists have been warning us for
years that extreme weather is going to
get more extreme
we're living it
in real time now
extreme weather cost america last year
99 billion let me say it again
extreme weather in the united states
cost the united states of america a
total of
99 billion dollars and this year
unfortunately we're going to break that
record
it's a devastating loss to our economy
and for so many communities
when we and we fail to curb pollution
from smoke stacks and tailpipes
and continue to use fossil fuels as we
do
we increase risk that firefighters face
but each dollar we invest
in resilience
saves up to six dollars down the road
when the next fire
doesn't spread as wisely as widely
and those investments also save lives
when i think about climate change i
think about
not the cost i think about
good paying jobs or create but i also
think about the jobs is there even an
audience here or are they just like in
an empty room with cameras in front of
them i sometimes wonder because we
haven't acted boldly enough we have to
build back you heard me say it a hundred
times not just build back but build back
better
as one nation we got to do it together
we'll get through this together we just
have to keep the faith
folks
we have
the bipartisan infrastructure bill
that's been passed that is bipartisan
and
i believe will get done
the so-called reconciliation bill that
has
another several trillion dollars in it
let me close by saying yeah when people
talk about the cost
of
the
buildback better
proposal beyond
the infrastructure let me remind you
the cost may be as much as 3.5 trillion
dollars
but to put that in perspective it's
spent out over 10 years
number one
and number two it's expected the economy
our economy will grow
to 366
trillion dollars gdp by that time we
can't afford not to do it 1.5
total
in terms of deficit
of that total amount in addition to that
the 90 of it's paid for
and so folks
we have to think big
thinking small is a prescription for
disaster right we're going to get this
done this nation is going to come
together and we are going to beat this
climate change thank you
all right
and off they go get vaccinated exactly
so there is joe biden in california now
about three a little under three hours
from now he will be over to a
rally for gavin newsom um the movement
to
keep gavin newsom of course supported by
newsom himself on the other side of that
tomorrow of course the california recall
election
is um larry elder and he will be having
a rally in a little bit we're going to
be going to that and i'm going to get to
some larry elder clips in a little bit
first
let me get caught up on super chats
because there are so many
um denver says david i was absolutely
gutted to see that gut feld is now the
leading late night comedy show from the
standpoint of ratings i tried to hate
watch it and could only make it three
minutes more than i survived denver
dan says do you ever debate intelligent
conservatives name them my friend name
them
brett says sir my conservative mom is
obsessed with the great reset as being a
new world order do you have any videos
of the orange of this conspiracy i don't
i'm so bored by the great reset
i really am
tgq says could you please engage talking
about sarah huckleberry's run i assume
you mean sarah huckabee sanders the
siphoning of money is incredible yeah i
haven't been following that that too
much but i want to learn more about it
photo says wish there had been time to
interview me kevin someone needs to
press him on his stock financial advice
i would be a huge conflict if he was
governor
yeah i i think you know
kevin's a nice guy i know i think he's
got no shot
says sir thoughts on trump reportedly
considering flying to brazil and
endorsing president barcelona at a mega
rally
if it happens please stream i haven't
heard of that but that sounds really
funny let's see trump brazil bolsonaro
rally
um
not seeing anything about it
trump open to endorsing bolsonaro's
re-election
possibly at a oh possibly at a mega
rally featuring them both
trump told confidence he's open to
publicly endorsing bolsonaro's
re-election potentially at a mega rally
in brazil where he and bolsonaro could
appear together side by side to rail
against what they each deem undesired
election outcomes bolsonaro is expected
to lose decisively against lula
has got wow
that's interesting man if that rally
happens i would have to be all over that
that sounds wild
i do want to say thank you to christy
roshan christy just signed up on my
website with the coupon code no recall
guys listen we're here
because if this lunatic republican larry
elder becomes governor of california
after tomorrow's recall
we are
really screwed it will be a signal
that is a very pro-trump signal i'm
going to go through some of larry
elder's outrageous comments and
policy positions in a moment so as a
reminder about the importance of no
recall today we have a coupon code no
recall let's test it and see if it's
working
where is all my stuff here ah here it is
you go to my website joinpakman.com
you go monthly or yearly yearly is is a
better deal
let's see if i can do this correctly
coupon code no
recall
no recall
60
very quickly
becomes
i'm not even going to say the number
because it's
60 goes away
let's put it that way okay
uh good
yeah good
okay
um all right good so we're caught up as
far as super chats go
um a few twitch prime sign up messages
junk saint signing up for six months
says if you see something say something
the 18th is approaching absolutely and
by the way if you know anything about
the video
of the in fact let's just look at it
because we have time
if you know anything about the pipe
bomber
in dc
please call the fbi please call the fbi
uh we have the video now
um
they've looked at
a bunch of different camera angles
and have started to ascertain the route
that the pipe bomber took on january 5th
these are the pipe bombs that were found
in dc on the day of the trump riots okay
they've started to figure it out
all these people were sending me
messages saying it looks like a woman is
it marjorie taylor green it looks like
there's a hidden
a ponytail in the um hoodie
i don't know anything but there is no
way in hell no one knows anything
someone must know something about this
person either they saw them elsewhere in
the city
or
they have a friend that mentioned
something
here they kind of put their backpack
down
and then a an individual comes by with a
dog
walking a dog
they kind of you know who knows what
they're doing they're trying to kind of
play it cool here comes the guy with the
dog
i don't know if they're applying an eye
drop there or what's going on maybe on
the phone
car goes by here comes the dog guy
and there they go just super casual just
just here i'm just here on the phone
uh
sir could i order a pizza oh whoop let
me grab my backpack with my pipe bombs
in it very dangerous individual
i'm open to the idea that it's a man or
a woman i think there's an idea here
that this this
i don't know i don't want to say looks
feminine but a lot of people are writing
to me saying there's something here
that's making me think this is a woman
then sits in a park just kind of
spending time with the pipe bombs in the
backpack
um you can review all this but in all
seriousness 1-800 fbi tips 1-800 fbi
tips 1-800 fbi tips
as well as tips.fbi.gov
you can send tips anonymously
we've got to be able to figure out who
this is folks
all right sirs
um
let's see then they get up here
and then this is a park near uh
one of the two the two locations were
sort of like near the rnc and near the
dnc
yeah i would look into subpoenaing the
dog that walked by seeing if the dog
remembers anything that's fair
folks it's clearly a deranged individual
does that narrow it down to three
quarters of the population
so that's that
um or and then 8 p.m so yeah i mean this
is all the day before the trump riots
808 pm shows back up over here i mean a
lot of walking around circuitous route
and then eventually planting the bomb
this is i believe out behind the rnc
still walking with the backpack
walking still has the backpack
we got to get this person guys we've got
to get this person
just circling circling circling
and signifi you know smaller and smaller
squares
and then that's basically the end as far
as we know of the uh yeah there we go
so let's do what we can on that okay
guys because that we i mean this is
important stuff we've got to figure that
out we should be looking at what shoes
they have all of these different things
every single one of these things i want
to say thank you to joshua nelson who
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code no recall no
no recall also thank you to larry riley
signing up with the code no recall
as well as trace swagger using the code
no recall putting us at 11. guys we'll
open phones if we get to 100 twitch also
counts
no recall is the code all right let's
continue
so as i already mentioned the numbers
looking better and better for gavin
newsom i believe we should keep gavin
newsom it doesn't mean gavin newsom is
perfect but larry elder would be an
absolute and total disaster
this has gone viral nicki minaj
the artist nicki minaj what's going on
here
there we go
nicki minaj tweeted a very strange
message about the vaccine
saying my cousin in trinidad won't get
the vaccine because his friend got it
and became impotent
his testicles became swollen
his friends his friend was weeks away
from getting married now the girl called
off the wedding over the swollen
testicles that's weird so just pray on
it and make sure you're confident
comfortable with your decision not
bullied it sounds more like an std quite
frankly
uh than
vaccine-based
it could is this even could this
possibly be real
let's write back
whoa
edgy content
um
what a bizarre situation yeah it really
makes more sense actually that's what
i'm going to reply
is it
maybe possible
the swollen
apple bags
were an
std from cheating
and that's why the wedding was called
off
oh man all right guys we gotta let's
let's let's power like this one right
here okay
um
man what what a world we live in
there are no stds that give you swollen
balls yeah i suspected that it's just
comedy guys
it's just comedy i'm considering this
like a free association sort of thing
all right so let's um let's continue
here is an event from yesterday with
larry elder actress rose mcgowan who
seems to has have gone completely off
her rocker she i guess supports larry
elder let's just listen to a little bit
of this and see if she's making any
sense i'll say to me americans are the
most uneducated
not wrong but they are wrong in this
it's under educated it's systematic and
it's done to you all on purpose
to keep you part of a complicity machine
that benefits few this is not a country
or a state for everyone this is a
country for the few this is a country
for people like hair gel in the bahamas
okay that's the reality and i really
wish what's that this is this is a
country like hair gel in the bahamas
what does that mean
better news it gives me no pleasure
to be the bearer of like truth which is
sometimes ugly
but do you want a society that has
gangrene on its leg but puts on a fancy
suit
and pretends it's not there while they
hobble in pain
or do you want to just stop
look at reality take your medicine
clean up the wound
and run
run free
why not change
why not go big
why not put a stake in it's funny
because it's like what however
delusional you think her speech is
there's nothing in it that would point
to voting for larry elder for governor
of california that's the funniest part
of it
because that's what this really is this
is good and this is evil
and if you're tired of people looking at
this country like it's the florida of
the world which is looked upon that way
because you know it's earned in a lot of
ways
what
um
i know this place has it in it to be
better
i know it does
i've met so many good people in this
country not the elites
absolutely not
but the person i meet you know that's
the housekeeper at the hotel i'm staying
at
um
who the team of housekeepers at my hotel
and the two butlers
these are really people that are
struggling
shouldn't even have that title because
she's a queen of a woman and then we
have the jennifer siebel newsomes of the
world
what why
why do you keep choosing that why do you
keep electing
that don't listen to their buzzwords
cult leaders
which is what these people are
i would know i grew up in one like i
said
they massage your mind
oh they keep you in fear
they keep you in doubt i kind of suspect
on the inside that this is all a lie
does anybody understand what the
reference like why would you why would
you vote for elder if you hear this
stuff even if you agree with it but i
don't want to be the one that stands out
and takes it on the chin well i'm here
to confirm for you it is a lie it is a
fact
it is a lie and it is it is a fact that
it is a lie that's almost like
um
this sentence is false
if it's true then it's false but if it
falls
very very strange but it's sort of on
brand let me see if there's any more of
this stuff
here they are arriving
what a really weird event man it's weird
let's see if there's any other clips
from that i don't know if she'll be at
today's rally
no it seems to be just this same clip
okay so we got that here's a few of
larry elder's political positions
um
let's take a look here
uh okay he is an ardent supporter should
i zoom this in a little bit
here we go
where were we
he's an ardent supporter of former
president trump frequently praising him
on twitter he was an early supporter of
trump's 2016 candidacy for president
2019 speaking to an audience about the
election elder said trump is a it was a
miracle he is almost god's son okay
that's why i'm con considering this sort
of
a referendum on trump
because this i mean it's there's it's
hard to have a more trump associated guy
than this guy
um
after biden won
and trump made false claims of fraud
while refusing to concede elders said he
did not believe that biden won
elder has argued that it's unfair to
blame trump for the trump riots
elder opposed tariffs imposed by trump
and trump's decision to draw down u.s
troops from afghanistan
okay
elder opposes minimum wage laws arguing
the ideal minimum wage is zero he
opposes universal basic income he
opposes california's unpaid family leave
law
elder has criticized the war on poverty
elder criticized chris christie for
accepting the architecture of the
welfare state and claimed the government
took almost 50 percent of the american
people's money through mandates
um
politifact rated it mostly false
elder has been critical of unions
he contends 15 000 california teachers
are incompetent
previously proposed thousands to be
fired
um
okay
in august of 21 elder came under
criticism for his history of statements
about women elder has said women know
less than men about political issues
economics and current events oh my god
in reference to the results from a study
from upenn
elder argued the demo party was often
successful with women because of their
emotionally driven but unsound policies
he said says women who took part in the
2017 women's march were obese and
unattractive and that premenstrual
syndrome stands for punish my spouse
has endorsed pregnancy discrimination by
employers and claimed that statistics
about domestic violence are exaggerated
to promote feminism
this actually may be completely
unbridled evil
guys are are we hold on a second i think
i need to ban someone here hold on a
second let me take a look
let me just explore
someone's getting my attention and i
think they probably need to get banned
uh yep they do okay see ya matt there
you go
um don't even bother appealing all right
let's continue
elder has often denied that a gender
wage gap exists elder contends employers
should be allowed to discriminate in
employment against women who plan to
have children
in his 2002 book he wrote that women who
choose to have children are not
dedicated to their jobs suggests they
lack a commitment to work
he reiterated reiterated it in 2021.
elder's former fiancee alexandra daidig
accused him of abuse oh okay deidig a
long time former radio producer for
elder who once worked as a prostitute
was engaged to elder for two years
dating said elder demanded she showed
devotion by having larry's girl tattooed
on herself oh my god and during an
argument brandished a gun in a
threatening manner after dating's
allegations became public the sacramento
b editorial board and fellow candidates
called for elder to withdraw
elder has denied the accusations
elder said in 2011 he had twice been
accused of sexual harassment denying it
both times in one case he defended
himself by implying the woman was too
unattractive for him to sexually harass
that's trumpian that's that's literally
a page out of trump's playbook actually
it was in 2011. so really trump took it
out of elder's playbook in a way
elder said quote if you had seen her you
would know that the picture would be a
complete defense i'm just saying
elder is against abortion he calls it
murder he argued roe v wade should be
overturned he called the decision one of
the worst the supreme court ever handed
down
elder has a history of anti-lgbt remarks
he has repeatedly used male pronouns
referring to trans women such as playboy
model ines rao and fellow gubernatorial
candidate caitlyn jenner
elder accused california having a soft
on crime ethos
he opposed a california law banning
police from using certain chokeholds
he opposed the law reclassifying
misdemeanors as misdemeanor's many
low-level drug and property crimes
wow this is one of the worst candidates
for any office ever it's not just that
this guy shouldn't be
california governor
this this may be one of the worst people
i've ever come across
public health and environment
during his media career elder
published and gave air time to
misinformation and fringe views on
scientific topics such as secondhand
tobacco smoke climate change and covid
he suggested secondhand tobacco smoke
has been exaggerated
rejects the consensus
he once described climate change as a
myth
he called it a crock
wow
in 21 he pledged to remove statewide
public health mandates for government
workers such as covet vaccine
requirements face mask requirements or
covet testing and then i see the
disinfectant is there a way we can do
something like that
by
injection inside
in 2021 he did not challenge a call-in
listener to his radio show who espoused
covet 19 misinformation suggesting
covet-19 vaccines
were part of a dangerous uh were
dangerous and part of a bill gates
orchestrated plot
and a page on his website actually
promoted the collins comments
saying you'll want to hear this
physician's take on the vaccines
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous
very powerful light
in the 2021 gubernatorial recall
newsome's campaign misleadingly
characterized republican opponents as
anti-vaxx
while elder opposes vaccine mandates he
supported vaccination being vaccinated
himself all right convalescent plasma
race elder defines himself as an
american who is black
rather than
as an african-american he called
systemic racism a lie blamed black lives
matter for crime
elder believes welfare is more harmful
to black families than slavery
elders suggest slave owners should
receive reparations for having their
property meaning slaves taken away from
them yeah i actually have um
some of those clips which we'll get to
in a moment here they are let's just
keep an eye on the rally okay it hasn't
started yet
let let me get caught up just on a
couple things so i don't fall behind i
do want to say thank you to dustin d
sivart
sardonic m
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 12 13 and 14. very much
appreciate that also want to say thank
you to people dumping in memberships on
the website using today's
special coupon code no recall we're here
against the california recall guys
okay so today
you can use the coupon code on my
website no recall no recall all right
people who just did that dari kohi
has just signed up
chris hutchinson is a new member
bradley baden has used the code no
recall
kristin schreiber is a new member
david uslan has signed up
and sarah clendworth signed up with the
coupon code no recall absolutely no
recall very much appreciate that
um
before we keep going
yeah actually let's do the candace owens
thing okay so here is larry elder a
couple weeks ago saying hey what about
reparations for the slave owners who
could no longer own the slaves right
behind that by the way when you
mentioned that uh the uk was ahead of us
they were do you know that the slave
owners were compensated
after they lost their quote unquote
property the government compensated
slave owners i didn't know that yeah and
so when people talk about liberations do
they really want to have that
conversation because
like it or not slavery was legal
and who's more gross larry elder or
candace owens so their property their
legal property was taken away from them
after the after the civil war so uh you
could make an argument that the people
that are old reparations not only just
black people but also the people whose
quote property close quote was taken
away after after the end of the civil
war there you go so a very strong case
then made there by a california
gubernatorial candidate larry elder
larry elder
the slave owner should get reparations
which they actually did i think it was
in um
was it in washington dc that lincoln
signed
for like 300 per slave for the slave
owners or something like that
uh something like that yeah
it was dc okay yeah very good
all right let's continue with the larry
elder here in this clip this was earlier
today elder would not commit to
accepting the results of the election
wow i'm shocked guys really surprising
larry elder the leading republican
candidate would not commit to accepting
the results of the election right
again whether or not you win or lose
will you accept the results of the
election tomorrow i think we all ought
to be looking at election integrity no
matter whether you're that means no guys
democrat an independent or republican
democrat let's all make sure that the
election is a fair election so let's all
work together no matter what the results
are to make sure that the results are
valid and legitimate and everybody now
what people need to start asking in
these particular cases i think this
might be jacob sauberoff um
not a friend of the show but sort of an
acquaintance let's say
um what what jacob should say and maybe
he will say it is
do you have any
reason to believe
there has been foul player the results
will not be accurate because absent that
what you're saying doesn't make any
sense larry who voted should have voted
let's all do that together is that a
commitment to accept the results of the
election tomorrow let's all do that
together let's all work together uh on
both sides of the aisle to make sure
that the election is a fair election
yeah so again i would really like to see
that question followed up specifically
with
do you have any evidence
that this is not being done fairly
and of course the evidence that they
will claim it is stolen
is that larry elder is not doing
particularly well okay here's two clips
of trump already starting up with this
here was trump on um
newsmax saying it's already been rigged
guys it's already rigged got the recall
election coming up in less than a week
uh it's actually happening as we speak
the polls appear to show newsome look
safer at this point larry elder is the
man uh that could take it from him what
do you think happens in california
well it's probably rigged they're
sending out all ballots it's all uh yeah
it's already it's just rigged
the casual nature with which this guy
just says elections are rigged is
horrifying the ballots are you know mail
out mail-in ballots in fact i mail them
out and you mail them in it's they're
just mailed in out exiting entering yes
you even have a case where you can make
your own ballot when that happens uh
nobody's gonna win except uh these
democrats so you know look they're very
good the one thing they're good at is
rigging elections so there's trump on
newsmax saying it's rigged here is trump
on
oh this is the same clip sorry this is
the same clip right let's see the the
ballots are you know mail out yeah okay
that's the same clip so he's already
saying it's been rigged
the gist of it guys that's the gist of
it
let's get to some other super chats i
missed a few here
um
where did i leave off
ah here we go i bet larry elder has a
poster of jessie lee peterson on his
wall
you love me
she hung up
it's amazing everything you're doing is
wrong exactly daniel says i haven't seen
total recall is it good i haven't seen
it either i don't know
a head case says i have a co-worker
willing to throw away his 30-year
pension to avoid our company's vaccine
mandate he was supposed to retire in
february
good luck to him godspeed
the two questions in the recall are not
mutually exclusive you can answer both
questions even if you answer no that's
important
that's important you can consider
question two as a plan b please spread
the message very important
david sir uh hold on i need my sir
material
david sir sir i don't know well can you
meet please make greater use of quote
tweets
we really need the full context
on the apple bag situation yeah how is
my tweet doing oh it's not not bad all
right
some of you guys agreeing there
a cousin's friend from the island yeah
it's it's all it's all pretty suspect
i'm not gonna lie
uh all right there we go
bay photo says rose mcgowan larry elder
worst table read ever
alexander hegstad with a very strong 219
norwegian kroner super chat says the
left side of politics in norway secured
a major victory in today's election a
majority in parliament and a new prime
minister in addition one of our most
left-leaning parties secured a major
mandate in parliament congratulations
alexander
uh it may not go so well here tomorrow
we'll see
how bizarre is it that we have the
technology to stream media instantly at
the same time that people like larry
elder exist in large numbers that is
scary
that is very very scary all right let me
get to my
unban request when you get banned on
twitch and it does happen you can submit
a request to be unbanned and i
adjudicate these one by one i have a
mallet or gavel for that
user warhead 420 man
showed up on the day of my last stream
within
looks like seconds of following which is
a requirement to chat
says
why does africa
use ivermectin
they were banned
and they are saying let me in please.
oh that's tough
i mean
we've explained why
in places where they have few other
medication options they just start
throwing whatever they have
at a
condition
i'm actually willing to unban this
person
but we're going to keep a close eye on
them okay
there we go
here is another user named fitzy j
they were banned
actually they were banned
last year
uh that's interesting they were banned
last year
after sending the message
marxist retards putting gender affirming
anti-racist task force to stop raping
and pillaging going on
in liberal shitholes
remember to comply with the criminals
they were banned they recently requested
an unban with the member with the
message
you are a 12 iq [ __ ]
who can't spew five words without being
a condescending prick
towards people more intelligent and with
more life experience
debate me any day on any of your
positions
also don't forget to get your booster
shot lmao
that is a perma-ban my friends if i've
ever seen one
all right
bye-bye
so there we have it we are all caught up
as far as unban requests as we stand by
for larry elder
in the state of california
um do you guys want to do a couple other
trump videos or some voicemails what's
on what what's the preference
yes it's been adjudicated for sure
let's do a couple voicemails and then
we'll go into some of the clips that i
have
we'll go um
we'll go one at a time okay here we go
all right just static
here we go
hi david this is zach calling from
nevada and i just watched your clip
about why joe biden's
approval rating was actually going down
and
it got me thinking
about a few things one mainly
um something i kind of wanted your
opinion on so i'm not calling for
anything crazy uh or calling for any
like
anything different than democracy
but
when i started
when trump was first president
um
one thing i really noticed is that there
were no or there didn't seem to be any
fundamental
uh
okay we're gonna move on it does go on
three minutes and then they call back
after getting cut off my instinct is
they did not get to the question
let's um
let's listen to some some more other
ones
hey david this is uh larry from texas in
australia i'm just finished listening to
a bit about the interview with susan
powell and
kind of wondering is this
more of that uh
that crazy video that i think i've seen
on netflix did they say susan powell who
what does anybody know what they're
talking about the interview bit about
did they say who jintao
what called the secret where
uh you basically
you if you believe something hard enough
eventually it will come true because
really that's kind of what
what all of these things sound like is
is if they just believe it hard enough
that'll come true
because i i i
i can't i'm lost for
what else
i just don't know what they're referring
to i'm sure i'm sure it's interesting
but
i just i'm not familiar with
what what they're referring to
you are exactly 101 correct
oh this is asmr bernie sounding guy
oh sydney powell sydney powell that must
be it
yeah
stay in fact they are reasons why we
should have never gone there in the
first place because they didn't want us
there our way of life is a way of life
not the way of life whoa we had no
reason whatsoever for our military
soldiers to be walking down
back in the day when we first got there
a year and a half after 9 11 and having
our u.s soldiers walking down the street
down iraq and slapping the hands of uh
civilian iraqi men holding hands in
public
that is their way of life not ours
necessarily unless you're you know an
american you're gay okay well that's
something else all right let's continue
with um
let's continue with
some other
voicemails
uh here we go
um i grew up in politics and i've been
very interested i'm a fresh californian
and i've been keeping track of new solar
jacksonville
canadian news and several other things
just to keep my pulse on things
i literally have direct
evidence of
news for jacksonville of being
anti-vaccine okay i don't know anything
about that station and local news is
really really really litigious
so i'm going to be very very careful
about that
um
i want to say thank you to do you grok
as well as nikki 206 for the twitch
prime subscriptions remember those don't
renew automatically
and if you're leaving five bucks in
bezos's pocket
that's not so good okay so make sure
that uh
that you re-up that twitch prime sub and
remember because the t today this is no
recall we're against the recall and
we'll be live maybe tomorrow with
results
we have a new coupon code today only
maybe tomorrow maybe next week maybe the
whole year but probably just today
coupon code no recall on my website you
save everybody wins everybody loves it
all right i'll thank
everybody couple more voicemails
this guy's making a really good point
he's saying you know he's a big big fan
and uh you know he's aware that i speak
of spanish and that there's a lot of
misinformation among the american latino
community and it would be great to do
something to reach that community now
i did a spanish show for like
nine weeks ten weeks right around the
election
i'm really really busy really really
busy so i have to you know i don't know
how much i can do but there should be
there should be more spanish language
content for
american latino folks very important
perfect voicemail
perfect voicemail thanks to a true gamer
tw and the bdizzle for re-upping and
creating new twitch prime subscriptions
let's um
kade smith says sir have you watched
season two of lupine yet yes i have
alex says you knew the person met sidney
powell right i didn't initially i
actually did not
i eventually uh eventually figured it
out
uh okay
here's a voicemail from the eggman still
really angry that i'm more empathetic
than him
hey dave i read the article empathy wars
i totally understand that the deaths of
these horrible people can negatively
affect their children and i i understand
that okay
but there's a point dave you have to
understand the deaths of these people
will benefit their children too there's
some point you know in the fulcrum in
there okay so when somebody is spreading
this mass propaganda the odds are their
children will grow up to follow in their
footsteps interesting at some point dave
the deaths of these people will
positively affect their their children
that's actually i mean it's spin but
it's not crazy
the eggman is uh hard to believe he's a
convicted felon right i get it it will
negatively affect them also to some
point okay but when they're really bad
it's a positive thing i listen to a
podcast it's all about uh biographies i
love people right people grow up with
horrible situations and turn out great
in life
the biggest question is it better to
grow up with a shitty father or no
father at all
shalom brother wow shalom and uh
bevakasha and all of the other
things um
what what is this and he also called
back
okay now this other one it's almost like
a private message to me we're gonna skip
over that for now okay
um here's a voicemail about the entire
jimmy from philly dr k thing
hi david
i was just watching your live stream
with uh dr k and and jimmy dore and i
haven't watched jimmy dore for a while
but oh my god
does this guy think jimmy from philly is
actually jimmy dore
is it at all possible on this planet
that someone watched the two-hour
session
with dr k and jimmy from philly
and thought
that was jimmy dore
is it is it even
is it even at all possible that that's
what someone came away believing that
that's the jimmy door that people are
talking about
i he's really down bad and it was really
sad to see where he's at
drug use and all
doing whippets the whole time that was
crazy
and um i i really hope he gets
you know back to where he once was i
can't tell if it's a joke it's very
nicely done
but that would be unbelievable that it
that would be really unbelievable
i think this is another one
i'm bummed that i missed most of the the
jimmy from philly live stream great job
it was a really um kind of eye-opening
um but i'm wondering if you will take
some of your viewers um questions for
next time um to ask jimmy um yeah that's
a good idea i would i would bring some
questions if jimmy wanted to do
something
i would do that i would do that that was
hard to understand voicemail but i would
definitely do that
i do want to say thank you to john
schleifer john just signed up on
joinpakman.com and his new member number
26 today also want to say thanks to
ferdsteiger who just got a twitch prime
subscription and is number 27
it is a perfect day a perfect day
for subscriptions let's do a couple of
the uh trump clips and then we'll get
back to this before the larry elder
thing
um
okay
uh on the 20th anniversary of 9 11 which
was two days ago donald trump
did a very sober and serious thing uh he
did commentary for a boxing match with
his kid
here is the i guess you would call this
a promo we're here at hard rock in
florida and we're going to have
hopefully
florida with a lot of great champions
for them they're going to be having a
good time i wouldn't want to do it a lot
of people wouldn't want to do it but
they look like they're going to have a
good time i just saw a couple of the
fighters and they love doing this stuff
so
if you had hinging forward at the waist
on your bingo card you can cross that
off right now watch evander and detour
we're gonna watch anderson silva
we're gonna have uh we're gonna have
some fun tonight
guys i think this is gonna be a lot of
levity at the end of a rather somber day
have a little bit of fun don't forget to
shoot me your questions i may have to
finally twist his arm a little bit to
find out about area 51 and the aliens or
whatever else you may want to ask about
that was the grift don all day spent the
day saying
get the pay-per-view of this fight
because
i might convince my dad to tell us the
truth about aliens like it was like a
sub-grift it was a secondary grift
we're gonna have some fun at the end of
a somber day and i'm just looking
forward to it some of the great fight
legends are here going to be a real
party then here's some of the uh
i guess you would call this commentary i
don't know that's weird
that was a fantastic job by a really
great this was the 20th anniversary of 9
11 by the way guys young man
he's got a big future and uh
we're just honored
thank you
god this is so stupid
i'm gonna get to the moonies clip every
everybody relax we're getting to that
thank you very much what an amazing
rendition of the national anthem
thank you very much everybody thank you
this is an honor to be with you and what
a great evening and
i think you're going to see an
incredible fight and jorge it's great
junior jorge
it's great to be with you guys and
champions we love you man also known as
jorge and special people special
warriors
jorge is more like what you would
imagine trump was used to say to michael
cohen when people would walk by that he
needed to get to sign
some kind of uh you know hush money
agreement
that's don jr
desperate for his dad to like him saying
this is the same chant we've been
hearing in football stadiums what what
desperation
well it's a great honor and thank you
very much thank you everybody very much
we love our country i love our country
thank you very much so we're going to
see a great fight tonight and uh we've
seen some good ones that last one we're
going to call it i think it's going to
be a short one you think it's going to
be well you've been calling them very
accurately i think this is going to be a
short one maybe you're right because
it's so future
look at this crowd anyway that was the
20th anniversary of 9 11 and then the
day before
trump said if he could fight anyone he
would fight joe biden because he could
knock him out in a second josh peter of
usa today
if you had to box somebody on saturday
night
who would it be
and what would the fight look like right
well if i had to pick somebody in the
world not only a professional boxer
because i'll take a pass on the
professional boxes that can be a very
dangerous subject but if you said do i
ha if i had to box somebody anybody i
think probably my easiest fight would be
joe biden because
i think he'd go down very very quickly
very very quickly you know he once said
oh i'd like to take him behind the bar
and he'd be in big trouble if he ever
did now i think biden would go down
within the first few seconds the first
few seconds it seemed i mean honestly
like let's just pretend to take this
seriously and then we'll get to the
trump moonies thing as we get very close
to this rally
i think in if it was boxing
i think trump would far more quickly be
exhausted by the weight of the gloves
than biden so i think biden would
probably have the advantage that's my
like we're pretending that this is a
real thing even though
this is a former president saying
he would fight the current president and
win i think the the weight of the gloves
would tire trump out so quickly that he
would just be a sitting duck
if it was more of a mixed martial arts
thing
my sense is trump's lack of speed
as soon as trump falls he's done right
like i don't know it's
yeah i don't know
okay
um all right next we've got so this is
an interesting thing
trump i i actually don't even understand
what this is so the description is trump
gave a speech for the deity of the
christofascist cult the moonies trump
praised the authoritarian mind control
cult for their incredible story yeah so
a church of
uh it's like sung yun moon or something
like that
the unification church oh hold on
the native form
yeah okay so this is this is what we're
talking about here
sun myung moon
was a korean religious leader known for
his business ventures and support for
political causes a messiah claimant he
was the founder of the unification
movement
members of which consider him and his
wife hak jahan to be their true parents
and of its widely noted blessing or mass
wedding ceremony
it's a whacked out cult okay and this
was trump's i guess speech to them it's
weird
i want to thank the universal peace
federation oh wait a second wait a
second
universal peace federation is something
else right
in particular
dr hawk jahan moon okay that's that's
the wife so maybe this is an offshoot
movement
a tremendous person for her incredible
work on behalf of peace all over the
world
her story of escaping from north korea
at five years old
at the outset of the korean war
is an amazing example of the power of
faith in almighty god
i also want to thank her late husband
reverend moon
for founding the washington times
oh god
for which i have tremendous respect and
admiration bizarre like i don't even
know that i have a commentary
necessarily because it's just all
completely crazy
completely crazy
um
okay so we looked at this already
yeah good
it just just none of it none of it makes
any sense
um i want to say thank you to afex as
well as subatomic for the twitch
subscriptions
also a huge thank you i can't thank
enough
lacey carter who just signed up at
joinpakman.com with the coupon code no
recall lacey thank you you were new
member number 30 today no recall
it's the code
you can use it today
let's see jimmy from philly says i hear
people want to ask questions set it up
nelson says jimmy from philly is
restreaming you very racist
armando says his ties tucked into his
pants
yeah i'm guessing you're referring to
trump there yeah we're not going to do
the jimmy stuff right now um i'm not
emotionally ready for that
but let's see let's just do a few more
voicemails as we close in on this larry
elder
uh
completely crazy rally
yeah hi david my name is richard uh i
live in maine
uh buddy i was born in 1950 i started
listening to you unfortunately i had
some medical issues from like 2008 to
2000
and my sister-in-law lives in montague
north of amherst she told me about you
she's got a phd in education she
was uh just uh do you refer to her as
doctor and then does someone pop up and
say not a medical doctor
okay
blown away by your addiction
you know you're
just the way you express yourself i've
been a fan of yours for a long time
thank you i i listen to you almost every
day i i do
record your show i don't see it live
very much
um i just want to congratulate you for
uh all your success uh everything well
deserved
and um you know i'm looking forward to
see what you have uh
in the future thank you but that's a
beautiful message of peace and love i
like that
um let's see
if we've got anything else here hey
david this is john from california
uh i was you know curious to to know
yeah don't use this all right we will
not use it let's see what else we've got
here
uh here's another
voicemail
hi david i'd like to get your opinion on
something
um you know we know when
joe biden was elected he was the
um
or rather we should say that donald
trump was the first one-term president
in roughly uh three decades um obviously
you know being replaced by joe biden
and my question is
with
politics in such a polarized state as it
is today um you know buying less than a
year in office and
already i think within the first couple
weeks of him being president people like
marjorie marjorie taylor greene were
drafting articles of impeachment was
kind of ridiculous
and i am just wondering if given how
polarized things are if you think um
we're going to see a lot more um
one-term presidents going i do think
that that's quite plausible actually
yeah that's a good point i think i think
it's eminently plausible for sure
david my name is james palmer
i am oh whoa and this guy goes on to
actually give sensitive information i'm
gonna skip over that that's i'll have to
listen to that in private
um
let's see what else we've got here
uh okay let's
see hey david um i really didn't know
how to
uh think let me start over all right
here's another one from the same person
let's see if they get it hey david so um
today is my sister's birthday and uh
she
all right and then they tried once more
and i think they did get it
hey david love your show um i have a
really strange conundrum i find myself
in um
today is my sister's birthday and just
start uh she's the only one of my house
snapbacks maybe um
i got the pfizer my parents got the
johnson johnson and my brother got the
moderna um she's the only one in my
family that vaccinated and today is her
birthday and her boyfriend just told me
that um
he was also not vaccinated that they he
wants to find the trip to go to florida
to go to a festival dear god birthday of
course and i don't know if i can chip in
and
morally contribute
to her going yeah don't don't don't
contribute to that absolutely do not
contribute to that
um horrible situation but don't um
don't do it
don't do it all right
let's see
what else we've got oh thanks to kiss
my toe beans
for subscribing via twitch also thanks
to junk saint for gifting a sub
and
taquito man for signing up appreciate
that
um
see what else we've got here
hey david um i was having a discussion
with some some other listeners um on
your discord debate channel and i was
wondering um it led me to wonder if you
would be
willing to have grover fur on your show
or if that's something you'd be
interested someone you'd be interested
in grover fur
what is that
grover fur
is an american author and professor of
medieval english literature
well i'm not familiar with this
individual
um
uh oh i'm looking at some of the
political stuff
yeah i'm gonna have to look into that
i'm not sure about that okay let me look
into that
hi david this is jessica from minnesota
um i'm calling um mostly because of this
new abortion thing in texas yeah um i i
have one argument i've never heard
anybody make
and two other arguments that i've heard
but very very seldom
um the first one is
why is it that you cannot use my kidney
if the president was dying
and i had the only kidney that would
save him in the whole world you cannot
have it without my permission you cannot
take my blood without my permission you
cannot have even my eyeballs or anything
else even once i'm dead
dead
but again you can't use my stuff you
can't grasp my stuff you can't take my
stuff you can't
why is it that you can sanction my
entire body
to save something okay this goes on to
the full three minutes gets cut off and
they call back three times so it appears
as though they don't actually get to the
point so i'm going to skip over it for a
little bit now but it was very
interesting let's go through some of
these voice
super chats here
matt says keep it up david i've been
watching you for years finally stable
enough to donate thank you matt thank
you
jonathan with a 2000 yen super chat
that's got to be like a million dollars
right 2 000 yen says assuming that
capitalism of any form even
well-regulated social democratic
capitalism would lead to the extinction
of humanity would you then accept
authoritarian socialism or embrace
humanity's demise so
the reason i find these questions kind
of pedantic
is first of all
um
the assumption is kind of like
you know
okay i mean i don't buy into the
assumption but let's assume that any
kind of capitalism even with any element
of capitalism means humanity goes
extinct
would i then accept authoritarian
socialism well you'd have to prove to me
that in the imaginary world where any
form of any capitalism element
uh we end up extinct that the
authoritarian socialism doesn't also
lead to extinct extinction so it's just
kind of like i don't know man maybe
um
let's see what else we have here jimmy
from philly owns you all right
okay i guess that's it i guess we're
caught up there as far as that goes
um hi um
sir pacman i um this is a new caller by
the way it's not the one you think my
name is
and i'm actually calling from germany
i'm a polish canadian
and i just watched here i i i watch all
of your videos
and i just wanted to um
express my gratitude thank you um i
the last video that watched was with the
mr radically
speaking to a psychiatrist
i don't know how you do it
i just wanted to say thank you for your
incredible work
and for how sane you stay and how
um
yeah you just have your
earrings this goes on for a while but
i'm kind of curious where it will go i'm
actually into this you don't lose your
your integrity
while doing all those interviews with uh
my pillow um guy or whatnot
i deserve you're on the cover of time
magazine again to say that i'm spreading
the word and all of my
friends are watching your show here in
germany as well love it well listen when
i was just in germany
i got recognized at a restaurant
and
maybe that person found out about it
from this person
all right very very good
let's see what else um
oh i haven't addressed by the way yeah i
got a disastrous haircut the other day
because what happened is my normal um
oh my god it's actually even worse than
i thought my normal person was so booked
up she's so in demand that i called and
i said ma'am please
i'll go anytime get me in and i could i
couldn't happen and so i ended up going
to like a barber shop
which i love the barbershop vibe you
know i always used to go to barber shops
but
it was a disaster
and the different problems are one
way too short here
relative to this stuff just like
this was buzzed relative to this stuff
they essentially gave me a mullet like
when i turned to this i mean like i
almost have a mullet
it's absolutely disastrous look at that
um
so anyway on um
friday
wait when am i doing it yeah friday i'm
getting it fixed but
it's really bad really really bad
i i just for whatever reason i didn't
address it
but now i have
um
all right
david you're skipping my chat super hats
no jimmy i read them i read them jimmy
you must have missed it
would you consider interviewing beau of
the fifth column
i mean i i have nothing against him it's
just
usually when i interview people that do
similar things to what i do it just
doesn't it doesn't do that well but
maybe he could join us on a live stream
that might be interesting
all right
um
let's listen to a couple more of these
hey david it's farmer dave again hey i
just listened to your uh farmer dave are
you calling me from a tractor coverage
of auntie vac's mom or anti-vaxx mom 2
or whatever the
kick doctor that you mentioned
sentiments or whatever it is she uh
he actually
exchanged
direct messages with her and she
explained that she was entering the
people buying the cards
uh into various state databases so that
they would show up as vaccinated even if
it was searched on the state's internal
database yeah we covered that actually
we covered that extensively and it's
quite criminal in fact
jonathan clarifying uh his question with
another 2000 yen i'm just wondering if
there are any possible situations under
which you would accept a more
authoritarian system of government or if
you would be willing to sacrifice
humanity for the sake of freedom come on
of course
if you're telling me
humanity depends on us instituting an
authoritarian system of government i
probably go with it right but it's sort
of like would you rather lose an arm or
only eat avocado for the rest of your
life
how would that be the situation
um
yeah if you say to me david either
everybody's dead
or we install an authoritarian socialist
well give me the authoritarian socialist
and hopefully at some point we can rise
up and remove him
and then go back to something that makes
more sense like you know i'm not a
sociopath
uh
i don't know guys i don't know
uh all right
oh i'm actually getting word that this
rally is cancelled
or that it's oh hold on a second is it
is it at 8 30 pacific time
oh that's insane i can't do that
all right well it was yeah it was
originally scheduled for over an hour
ago then it got rescheduled to 10
minutes ago and now i'm being told it's
actually 8 30 pacific that this is all
wrong
okay
all right well listen you know what
we're going to do um
let's just call it and then tomorrow
night my intention will be to stream the
results of the recall remember no recall
no
recall
no recall
no recall okay
um but let's plan
to get back together here tomorrow night
and hopefully have early results
on no we want to have a positive result
from the standpoint of no tomorrow on
the recall okay
uh great to see everybody
we've got so much more happening we will
see you tomorrow hopefully with good
results from california
you